Hey everyone, we are in our chapter 13 work problems.
I have a whole bunch of questions here that we're going to look at on price discrimination.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the first one.
What is the main goal of price discrimination?
Well, we know that with price discrimination the firm is attempting to take surplus from consumers in the market.
So they're trying to extract that extra value from consumers, turn it into firm profits.
So let's find an answer that looks like that.
And C is going to be our answer there.
Convert our consumer surplus into our producer surplus.
So you're charging these consumers based on what their willingness to pay is.
This allows us to extract some, maybe all, if we're doing first degree price discrimination of the consumer surplus.
And so that actually allows us, the firm, to turn that back into producer surplus.
Question two, which of the following is an example of third degree price discrimination?
So, um, we're gonna be looking at these.
Charging each customer.
No, that's first degree price discrimination.
Charging students less than professionals for software.
Yeah, that's our answer there.
I don't even have to go any further because we're segmenting the market based on something.  Okay.
And that's what third degree price discrimination does.
It segments the market based on age, occupation, location, whatever it happens to be in charges different prices based off of that segmentation.
Here we're just assuming that our students are going to be more price sensitive, that is more elastic than what our professionals are going to be.
And that's a pretty safe assumption.
So that's why we choose B as our answer, because of segmentation in there.
How can a firm prevent arbitrage when practicing price discrimination between markets?
So arbitrage is the thing where consumers buy at a low price and they resell at a higher price and they take the profit from that resale.
And in order to have price discrimination actually work, you have to be able to prevent arbitrage from happening.
So let's look at the SETI single uniform price.
That doesn't necessarily prevent price discrimination.
You look at any Taylor Swift concert.
Allow product resale to increase access.
No, that doesn't do it either make it difficult or costly to resell the product between groups.  There's your answer.  C.
We don't need to go any further.
That is our answer here.
What we're trying to do is basically use things like non transferable licenses in the sale of the good tie products, some kind of identity.
So you have to show your license or show your student id.
So that would make it more difficult to resell things like that, to cause that difficulty to increase between the resale between two groups.
Robinson Patman act was designed to do what?
And the answer here, we're gonna get an explanation here in a second.
But the answer is prevent price discrimination that harms small businesses.
So the Robinson Patent act came out in 1936, targeted anti competitive price discrimination, really looking at larger firms selling at discounts to other larger firms and harming businesses, smaller businesses in the process.
So your large sellers would sell to your large buyers.
The small buyers, like, hey, what about me?
Well, that's what the Robinson Patman act came in.
All right, so that's what it was designed to do.
Which pricing strategy is most likely to violate the Robinson Patman Act?
So again, Robinson Patman act was looking at specifically targeting these large sellers from selling to these large buyers at discounts that the small buyers, buyers couldn't get.
So let's look at these.
Offering a temporary promotion.  Never stop.
No, Everybody looks like they might get that.
Selling the same product to large and small buyers at different prices.
Yeah, that's your, that's your answer.
And the cost justification part is really key there.
Without cost justification, if that large buyer can have some type of cost justification to, or large seller has some kind of cost justification to the large buyer, then it's okay.
But they don't have that cost justification in there, then it's not okay.
It's a violation of the Robinson Patent Act.
So we do allow these discounts tied to volume.
So if your large buyers buying in such bulk that they can get that cost change, then it's okay, but otherwise it's not okay.
Which of the following is an example of first degree price discrimination?
This is also called the perfect price discrimination because we're charging each consumer their willingness to pay.
Let's look at what our answers are.
Offering senior discounts.
That's not, that's more of a segmentation or third degree price discrimination charging different prices by country.
Again, third degree price discrimination, you're looking at location as a way to segment markets and a car dealer negotiating different prices with each buyer.
Yeah, that's your answer right there.
You're figuring out what each buyer's willingness to pay is and then you're charging them their willingness to pay.
So you're extracting all the consumer surplus for or most, maybe not all, but most of the consumer surplus out of that market and turning it into producer surplus.
All right, next question.
Which of the following is best classified as second degree price discrimination?
So we talk a little bit about this.
I believe in this chapter we don't talk much about it because second degree price discrimination is more indirect price discrimination.
It's where you look at things like metering quantity sold, volume sold, self selection into particular, particular goods being purchased.
So we're going to keep those things in mind while going down these answers.
Offering subscription discounts to students, that's not going to be our answer.
That's going to be third degree.
Charging higher prices for shipping overseas.
Offering lower per unit prices for bulk purchases.
That is going to be second degree price discrimination.
Here you're going to allow self selection take place because people who won't get in those bulk purchases will self select into making those bulk purchases.
So that's why this is second degree price discrimination.
And our last question here.
Movie theater has two customer groups, students and adults.
Students are willing to pay $8, adults willing to pay $12.
Marginal cost of each ticket, zero.  How nice.
And then we have 100 students and 100 adults who plan to attend.
And our scenario says we can charge 8 to everyone or 8 to students and 12 to adults.
So we are trying to practice third degree price discrimination in that second part of the scenario there.
So it says how much additional revenue does the theater earn from price discrimination?
And this is why firms want to price discriminate.
Let's look at the actual numbers here.
So we could charge eight to everyone.
We have 200 total people.
So 200 times eight gives us $1600.
Or we could charge eight to students and 12 to adults.
And this is what theaters do.
We get 800 plus 1200.
And that gives us a total amount of revenue of $2,000.
The difference between those is $400.
And that is how you take price discrimination, put it in action and you take consumer surplus out of the market and put it into your firm's profits.
All right, that is it for our Chapter 13 questions.
Hope you've enjoyed it.